while we wait to reunite with DOM Letty
and all the rest we're passing the time
by rounding up all the spoilers and
rumors we can get our hands on salute me
familia after spinning its wheels for
four commercially successful but
critically uneven films The Fast and the
Furious franchise really took off with
2011's Fast Five a slick exuberant heist
action flick that bore little
resemblance to the smaller state street
racing movies that had come before it
one of its biggest upgrades came in the
form of Dwayne the rock Johnson as Luke
Hobbs a Diplomatic Security Service
agent who served as the film's
intimidating antagonist Hobbs would go
on to follow in the footsteps of former
FBI agent Brian O'Conner joining up with
the fast family rather than trying to
apprehend them for their big hearted
crimes that is gotta go to work
Jason Statham also joined the fast in
the Furious series as rogue assassin
Deckard Shaw the family's deadliest
antagonist at the end of Fast & Furious
6 he was revealed to be the one who
killed Han back in 2006 as The Fast and
the Furious Tokyo Drift
while many fans still haven't forgiven
Shaw for that he also wound up joining
forces with Dom's crew and was
responsible for saving Dom's infant son
from cypher in the fate of the Furious
but while Hobbs and Shaw proved to be so
popular that they got their own spin-off
film don't expect to see them in the
franchise's upcoming ninth film in an
interview with MTV News Johnson
confirmed that he and Statham will not
be appearing there although he left the
door open for an appearance in the
already confirmed tenth installment the
absence of Luke Hobbs leave some mighty
large shoes to fill and who better to
step into them than that other wrestler
turned actor John Cena
while no character description has yet
been released Universal has confirmed
that Cena is indeed joining The Fast and
the Furious family and his character is
to absolutely no one's surprise a badass
beyond that who Cena will be plain as
anyone's guess although it would be well
within the tradition of the franchise
for him to make his entrance as a
villain Johnson and Statham made the
leap from antagonists to heroes as did
Luke Evans as fast and furious 6 bill
and Owen Shaw who helped save Tom's son
in fate of furious but Charlize Theron's
spatty cipher may also be getting her
own spin-off hinting that she too may
wind up switching sides at this point it
would almost seem weird for a fast in
the Furious movie to bring on a new big
name and have them not play a villain
Chris Morgan has been writing The Fast
and the Furious script since Tokyo Drift
but with Morgan stepping away to pin
Hobbs and Shaw fast 9 has tapped Daniel
Casey to take over writing duties for
the ninth installment he's best known
for 2018 skin but Casey grabbed the
studio's attention with his script for
the heavy a subversive superhero movie
those currently in the works from
producer JJ Abrams it's fitting that
Universal would look to a superhero
writer for the next Fast and Furious
movie considering the larger-than-life
direction the franchise has drifted in
during its latest installments the
stunts have been growing increasingly
more out
this world for years fate of the Furious
even includes jetpacks like the one the
Falcon wears in the Avengers movies
Digicel does character and his cyborg
like abilities might not just be a
one-off thing to be rock Superman
perhaps Casey's hiring hints that
superpowers won't be limited to
spin-offs and that they'll already loose
physics of The Fast and the Furious
series would get shrugged off entirely
while most of Dominic Toretto's crew
joined the franchise somewhere between
the second and fifth films Michelle
Rodriguez has been there from the very
beginning playing Dom's girlfriend and
eventual wife Letty Ortiz
however while Letty and Dom were closer
than ever at the end of the fate of the
furious Rodriguez herself was a
different story
in an Instagram post in 2017 Rodriguez
wrote that she might consider walking if
the best franchise didn't give women a
more prominent role faced with a future
without one of the family's longest
tenured members or perhaps simply
because the studio agreed with Rodriguez
and wanted to do right by its female
fans Universal agreed to her stipulation
that she would only return if they hired
a female writer for the ninth movie
although we still don't know who the
woman is who will be helping Daniel
Casey pin the script for Fast 9 we hope
that Rodriguez gets her wish and that
the script does indeed show the amazing
women of the franchise some love during
the filming of Furious 7 Paul Walker who
had been playing Dom's best friend and
brother-in-law Brian O'Conner since the
first movie was tragically killed in a
car crash instead of writing a similarly
sad fate for Brian the ending of the
film was rewritten to bring closure to
Brian's story with him riding off into
the sunset
however Vin Diesel announced in 2017
that Jordana Brewster will be reprising
her role as Mia
Dom's sister and Brian's wife for Fast 9
given how important it was to the entire
cast and crew of Furious 7 that Brian
receive a happy ending it'll be
interesting to see how the series
chooses to bring back Mia without
killing Brian off screen or splitting
them up
hopefully Brian's absence will be
explained by him staying home with the
kids while Mia goes off with her brother
to help save the world it seems like
every fanbase in every franchise wants
the same actor to join up and whoa up
their prospective universe Keanu Reeves
information has been
Turkey about just how big Reese's roll
will be in the film could he be the
villain and if he is the villain will he
be the behind-the-scenes type or out
there John waking it up and jumping from
moving vehicles like a seasoned vet or
will he even be in the movie at all
plenty of websites reported that Reeves
would appear in Hobbes and Shaw and
spoiler
he didn't just because people want Keanu
in the movie doesn't mean it'll happen
just ask MCU fans while the original The
Fast and the Furious was filmed entirely
in and around Los Angeles the series has
since shot all over the world you're a
long way from home
this is Brazil in Fast 9 the series will
be returning to the UK with production
confirmed to be underway in London other
shooting locations include Los Angeles
and Hawaii it's important to keep in
mind that a shooting location doesn't
necessarily guarantee that part of the
film will be set in the same place for
example in Fast & Furious 6 London stood
in for Moscow and in the fate of the
Furious many of the New York scenes were
actually filmed in Cleveland still most
of the time when the Furious films
travel abroad it's because at least part
of the movie is set in the country
they're filming in so it's a safe bet
that DOM and his crew will be hopping
across the pond for some of fast 9 in
addition to spending some time in at
least one more tropical locale when it
comes to gender representation the Fast
and Furious family has always been
pretty heavy on the dude side of things
fortunately it seems as though fast 9
may be taking some steps to correct that
Michelle Rodriguez Jordana Brewster and
Natalie Emmanuel are already set to
reprise their roles as letting Mia and
Ramsay respectively along with the
as-yet unannounced female writer joining
the creative team in addition to these
three established women of The Fast and
Furious world Chris bridges aka Ludacris
who has played Tesh Parker in the series
since too fast to furious in 2003 took
to his Instagram in early 2019 to tease
an intriguing possible addition to the
cast he posted a photo captioned
masterminding of himself his F&F cast
mate Vin Diesel and an actress
moviegoers might recognize from John
wick chapter 2 Ruby Rose of course a
single Instagram post doesn't
necessarily mean that Rose is joining
the Furious family even ludas returned
for Fast 9 hasn't been confirmed yet
although it seems pretty likely that
he'll be back in action even if the
photo was taken just during the chill
hang out among pals it's worth noting
however the diesel is one of the
masterminds of the franchise both on
screen as DOM and behind the scenes as
producer considering that Rose
previously appeared alongside diesel and
XXX the return of xander cage and that
she's set to find new fame as the
defender of Gotham City in the CW's
upcoming Batwoman series Rose seems more
than equipped to join this team of
masterminds in the same Facebook live
video in which Vin Diesel
Jordana Brewster z-- return to the Fast
and Furious family
he also delightedly revealed that after
a few years absence and a trip onboard
the Starship Enterprise
director Justin Lin would be helming
both the 9th and 10th movies in the
series Lin joined The Fast and the
Furious series in 2006 taking the reins
on the Fast and the Furious Tokyo Drift
and staying with the film's through
2013's Fast & Furious 6 other directors
took over after that with James Wan
coming aboard for Furious 7 and F gary
Gray stepping in for the fate of the
Furious but now Lin is back for what are
expected to be the final two
installments in the saga diesel said
prior to the release of the fate of the
Furious that the reason he decided to
continue the franchise following Paul
Walker's death while filming the seventh
movie was because Walker quote promised
eight he went on to explain that the
fate of the Furious would kick off a new
trilogy that would change the series
considering that the plot of fate
involved literal nuclear warheads it's
safe to say they delivered now that Lin
who was responsible for taking the
series to new extremes as returning to
Shepard the series through its final
films things only seem like they're
going to get bigger Nathalie Emmanuelle
first joined The Fast and the Furious
crew as the mysterious master hacker
Ramsay in Furious 7 after she was
kidnapped for inventing a hacking device
called the gods I needless to say she
was subsequently rescued by Dominic
Toretto and the family and the next time
we saw her and fate of the Furious she
was an indispensable member of the team
and now that we know she's returning for
fast 9 we can only hope that Ramsey will
be a member of the fast family all the
way until the end of the road we know
Emmanuelle is on her way back thanks to
a tweet she made back in June but that
wasn't the only part of it that got fans
excited in addition to her announcement
she also included a row of emojis that
look a whole lot like the rest of the
core cast including Tyrese Gibson and
Ludacris their characters Roman and tej
have long been assumed to be returning
for Fast 9 but hadn't been officially
confirmed emojis may not be the most
official means of confirmation but it's
looking increasingly likely that the
holdfast family - their spin-off pals in
Hobbs and Shaw will be joining forces
yet again for Fast 9 maybe they can
finally figure out what her full name is
let me ask you one question
you can ask me anything anything what's
my last name check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about The Fast and the Furious
franchise are coming soon subscribe to
our YouTube channel and hit the bell so
you don't miss a single one
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]